Kanye West has endorsed Georgia  Republican Senate candidate Herschel  Walker and in a sense it's really a  match made in heaven the guy who doesn't  understand any political issue Herschel  Walker but since we don't control the  air  is being endorsed by Kanye West who  seems to ignore reality on just about  every political issue this is our  president  Herschel Walker might win if you vote in  Georgia understand that this is not fun  in games the polling has shifted  significantly in favor of Herschel  Walker who doesn't make sense on any  issue is a liar is dishonest is not a  good person  please vote if you're voting in Georgia  no matter where you're voting please  vote but very very very important  Georgia voters should vote